Now, this is a really tricky question and that's why we saved it for last.
I always save the good stuff for last.
This problem involves two masses
connect by a string which is draped over this pulley, so it's free to rotate.
What we're going to do is solve this question algebraically to get an equation that tells us
"If we let the system go, what will happen?
Will it accelerate counterclockwise or just stay in this sort of equilibrium where nothing moves?"
In regardless of the motion, I want to know some numbers.
I want to be able to quantify this. What exactly will the acceleration be?
Let's see if we can solve this.
When we look at a complicated problem like this, we don't want to get scared.
The first thing we want to do is make some sense of it in our heads.
once we do that, we might have some bright idea about how we approach it quantitatively.
When I'm doing this sort of thought experiment in my head,
one question I'm going to ask is--what happens when the masses are equal?
Will this whole system be motionless? Will it accelerate clockwise?
That would mean this guy goes up and this guy goes down.
Or will it accelerate counterclockwise?
That would mean this mass will go up, this one would go down,
and the pulley would spin that way.
I'm also going want to think about "What will happen when m₁ is the bigger mass?
This guy is heavier than this guy. Or when M₁ is the smaller mass?"
Can you, for each of these three cases, tell me what you expect the motion to look like?